hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
top 5 bio serien reihe dingsbums klar
und wahr wurde mehrfach angefragt dass
ich doch mal meine top 5 cheats
vorstellen soll und da muss ich
natürlich wie bei jedem top 5 video
wieder einmal am anfang sagen dass das
ganze meine meinung ist das sind die top
5 sieht die ich am besten finde nicht
die wo ich sage okay die waren und deren
dem forum auf platz eins das muss bei
mir auf platz eins ein nein das ist
meine eigene reihenfolge von mir egal
die nummer eins der jetzt gerade
eingeblendet und zwar spontan etwa hier
beziehungsweise nicht gemeint sondern
platz nummer fünf man staunt ca hier
irgendwo hier in diesem radius und wenn
man sich schon um guckt man sieht
überall ein ice bei ihr um und ich finde
gerade das ist extrem cool jetzt für den
winter deswegen ist es auch mein platz
fünf weil er zieht noch nicht so viel
hinzufügt abermals bauunterhalt direkt
in dem eis bei jungen viele denken sich
vielleicht im winter auch kommen ich
spiel mal in einer welt wo schnee liegt
wo ich ihn zugefrorenen fluss ab und vor
allem auch ganz cool da hinten ist
direkt mehr was auch eingefroren ist
hier ist ein kleiner see der
eingefordert also man hat relativ viele
coole sachen man kann hier auf jeden
fall so einem winter achterbahn bauern
und so ich hatte ja mal das christmas
kraft let's play
eventuell kommt er wieder im dezember
mal schauen ob ich das alles auf die
reihe kriege mit studien etc
und hier sind auf jeden fall war richtig
coole sachen wo man sagen kann haye
kommen da kommen weihnachts gegen auf
und ja das ist mein platz zu machen
diesen zieht der gerade eingeblendet ist
mein platz nummer vier ihr könnt ihr
auch einfach mal pausieren also derzeit
schon wieder ausgewählte dabei könnte
einfach passieren wenn ihnen dann
abschreiben wollte oder einfach in die
beschreibung schauen da stehen ganzen
ist auch drin und zwar habe ich den
schon mal bei einer facts folge benutzt
hier seht ihr da fallen die blöcke
runter hier habe ich schon mal perfekt
aufgebaut
es ist ein sehr cooler survival sieht
man hat irgendwie nahezu gar kein holz
also das wird komisch wenn man darüber
legen möchte irgendwie allerdings ist
das war also die einzige insel da vorne
ist auch sein kleiner inseln und das
coolste daran man spontan direkt wir
haben zwar hat gesehen was bauen direkt
auf dieser insel und ionen ist direkt
ein wasser tempel
das heißt man hat ihr diesen meeres
tempel wo man irgendwie so ein paar
leute besiegen kann ob das ohne holz
überhaupt möglich ist frage ich mich
selber so ein bisschen allerdings hat
man halt diese insel natürlich
irgendwann kommt dahin auch noch mal
irgendwas anderes
dezember jetzt hat man die erst mal nur
das hier und da hinten direkt mehrere
stempel das war mein platz vier und bei
als ihr müsst auf jeden fall die ersten
plätze bauten die sind so geil aber egal
jetzt kaum besser platz beim dritten
platz baut man in etwa ihr irgendwo hier
in diesem radius und wir sehen schon
okay hier ist so zu machen dass bio hier
sondern etwas flachland bio hier habe
mir ein bisschen wüste die sich hier so
ein bisschen durchzieht und dahinter
noch ein bisschen größer wird hier haben
wir einen
denn das noch mal hat das nicht denn
dumm zu heiß ist und ich bin ich auf
jeden fall mag ich hatte mich eigentlich
ganz geil ich mag das biom ganz geil ok
luca einfach weil hier der gebrannte
clay ist ich liebe gebrannten clay das
ist so ein schöner blockparteien kommen
und ich uns ja diese meinung und auch in
kempten minecraft 2 waren wir einmal so
verliebt in diesen play allerdings ihr
seht schon mal spott hier vorne man hat
hier noch was minecraft wissen bin ich
echt auf dem aktuellsten stand wie heißt
das da hinten noch mal ich glaub ja also
wir haben auf jeden fall relativ viele
billionen rennen haben wir noch in
sumpfigen hier mit ein paar berge das
blabla und mittendrin ist eine pyramide
und wenn wir diese pyramide reingehen
und die einfach mal so ein paar blöcke
kaputt schlagen und dann unten springen
sehen wir schon drei diamanten ich nehme
das erst mal raus was hier alles so drin
ist hier sind noch ein bisschen rotten
flesh und auch noch ein paar knochen
hier ist ja auch wieder machen
vielleicht die haben da auch noch ein
paar knochen geht es wieder rotten flesh
ein paar knochen und auch noch reisen
und wir haben dann insgesamt 42 wie ich
gehe hier sind die luft sprengen
wir haben auf jeden fall ein paar
richtig coole sachen da ich fliege
einfach gegen die decke aber werde auf
jeden fall mal richtig coole sachen hat
und am start neuen diamanten und hier
noch ein paar sachen wenn ihr jetzt
denkbar voll cool wartet auf jeden fall
noch die nächsten beiden sitzt da wird
es noch richtig hammer und mich würde
erstmal sagen das ist halt ganz geil
weil ich ganz ganz viele biome
aneinandergrenzenden und in der mitte
steht einfach so eine pyramide finde ich
ganz cool den zieht hier ist auch noch
so eine mehr oder weniger ist doch keine
schlucht aber naja das auf jeden fall
der platz zwei platz meine lieben
freunde ist recht kuriosen entfernt ich
muss dich total am verrecken als ich
geboren bin und zwar ist diese sieht ein
pferdes sieht der 68 pferde enthält
meine preetz als ich habe ja schon
gesagt komm ich geboren hier und da war
direkten fährt am verrecken hier
wir sind hier jetzt mal so ein paar
weiße ponys hier sind ein paar esel mehr
oder weniger hier sind ein paar
gepunktete da sind auch noch so ein paar
pferde dann haben wir da hinten noch ein
paar pferde und da vorne sind auch noch
pferde hier sind blumen da hinten sind
aber auch noch zwei pferde hier sind
noch pferde und da sind wir da hätten
sie aber fair.de hier sind überall
pferde am start das ist richtig richtig
krank und wir haben direkt ein
ein kleines dörflein und wir haben hier
jetzt fängt sie aber auch an zu ruckeln
also ich weiß nicht woran es liegt dass
es bei mir teilweise echt einfach so
faymann berichtet von immer wurzach
framework
zwischendrin mal wieder flüssig und
jetzt gerade läuft wieder extrem flüssig
ich habe einfach mal ein treiber
aktualisiert von dem von dem mann im
grafikkarten ich habe ein video dvds 87
m
und ja also da vorne haben wir auf jeden
fall sollte eine mit stempel und jetzt
können wir hier mal eben auch uns rein
bewegen und dann haben wir hier in dem
ich endlich dürfen wo wir auch ein paar
coole dahin in der hütte drin haben und
zwar direkt erstmal coole rüstung hier
am start sechs diamanten und drei eisen
68 pferde richtig geile landschaft finde
ich und einfach so ein hexenhäuschen ist
auf jeden fall richtig cool dass mein
platz 92
und jetzt kommt's platz ich bin gerade
hier geht die welt baut sogar gerade
noch auf uns passt erst mal platzen
eines den zitierte grabschen
eingeblendet gesehen ganz easy und loben
keine ahnung wie ich das mache also ich
spontan etwa hier ihr werdet dann auch
irgendwie um den dresden hier haben wir
erstmals einen richtig geilen fluss eine
geile höhle mit lover oder baum direkt
an verbrennen ist aber hier auf jeden
fall richtig coole kann man was richtig
geiles drin bauern eben wie hier so eine
glas plattform oder was weiß ich auf
jeden fall richtig geile möglichkeiten
der stieß nicht daheim
allerdings interessiert uns das gar
nicht sondern hier sind erst mal extrem
coole bieren hier die savanne wir haben
hier diesen substanzen mit dieser höhle
richtig cool aber wir können auch
einfach mal in diese richtung hinten
fliegen und dann sehen wir schon dass
bei eine pyramide
hier ist aber nicht nur eine pyramide
sondern hier ist einerseits hat diese
pyramide dann ist da hinten noch ein
dorf da ist allerdings keine schmiede
also auch nichts besonderes am start
halt einfach nur dann diese
villiger mit dem man ein bisschen
handeln kann allerdings eine pyramide
ist dort hinten am start die seht ihr
schon und ich habe hier wieder so ein
paar
ich weiß nicht woher das kommt jetzt
sind sie wieder stabil bei 60 fps und
jetzt jetzt guckt jetzt ist wieder so
ein bisschen ruckeln also ich verstehe
nicht dass nied und jetzt kommt wieder
alle partyfans das liegt wohl irgendwie
einfach an meinem pc oder so ist man zum
beispiel letztens bei den beiden
gleichauf kleinste minecraft video auf
einmal alles balla flüssig 600 ps
durchgängig und jetzt auf einmal hier
immer so ab und zu verändern brücher
aber darum geht sollte nicht sondern wir
schauen jetzt einfach mal diese pyramide
hier rein sehen hier sind geile items
anstatt hier ist es mit dem and a more
für ein pferd wir haben zwei einen horse
amos für ein pferd und hier drin sondern
auch ein bisschen gold also wir haben
insgesamt in dieser pyramide 7 diamanten
22 gold 218 reisen unterhalt noch diese
diamond race arme und iron horse arme
und auch eine ganz coole story of staat
also da hinten gerade mit dieser höhe
war extrem cool und jetzt hier halten
auch dieses dorf wo man mit ein paar
bildern einfach handeln kann man hat die
keinem schmiede oder irgendwie sowas
arbeit eigentlich ganz nice und wir
haben hier auch wieder coole story man
schlüssel also wirklich hier mit sondern
mit seinen türmchen und so das sind echt
coole der kindheit darin eine stärke
fällt mir auf jeden fall sehr dieser
sieht und ich will auch sagen damit war
es das für dieses video heute montag und
zwar wenn das meine top 5 sieht es war
meine meinung um welche sachen sollte im
nächsten top 5 video gehen schreibt uns
in die kommentare von dann sehen wir uns
im nächsten video wieder